um i'm in the show there we go live
hello everyone um we are coming to you
live on
what are we on we're on facebook
instagram
uh what are we on uh linkedin
what other things were there that we're
live on twit twitter youtube all the
things
live to do find your why questions and
answers
hopefully i'll have answers to your
questions we just launched the um find
your y course
a few weeks ago and lots of people
called in with tons of questions
as they were going through the process
about uh how to find their why
and so we thought why don't we do a live
and answer questions live
and help people who are finding their
why actually um
actually do that so that's what we're
doing here we are
i'm just eating some blue corn chips
because i'm starving um
but we should just jump right in right
we have people joining us from all over
the world which is always amazing to me
um greece where greece and india
and colombia tanzania i mean it's
amazing i'm always flattered and honored
some of you are up really late um to
join me
so hello everyone and hello everybody on
instagram
where i'm also live looking at you right
now how are you okay
so let's jump right in because why delay
um okay i'll stop eating chips that's
really probably really annoying for
everybody
but they're super tasty um okay
michelle b um a good name for a pop star
uh is it ever too late to figure out our
why
as a 50 year old married mother of four
i feel like i am
i uh like i just am where i am
i'd love to know my why but will it make
such a difference to someone
uh contentedly settled in their life the
only criterion
to want to know your why uh to knowing
your why is that you want to know your
why that's
pretty much it um and so if you're
content and happy
and um and you don't feel like you need
it and you trust your gut and
life is good then then you're fine but
if you have the curiosity to know it
it really is quite enlightening
regardless of where you are in your life
it's not
a tool simply to fix broken things
that's not what it's for
it's a tool for clarity and not only do
you get clarity
from knowing your why about things
you're going to do and decisions you're
going to make and
and things that you want to do but it
also actually helps you get clarity on
the past
once you articulate your why you can
look back in your life and you can see
almost instantaneously that when things
are going well and you're in the flow
and things are working
you can see that your why is present and
you can also see
that when things were a struggle or more
difficult or more stressful even though
you
you know you knew quote unquote what you
were doing um
you'll find that your why was fuzzy or
absent that it wasn't there
so it's actually a remarkable tool for
clarity from the past but also gives you
clarity for
for uh future decisions so regardless of
how old you are regardless of your lock
in life
regardless of whether you're struggling
or happy content it's
all irrelevant the question is if you'd
like that clarity and you'd like to know
that filter
it's an amazing confidence builder just
to know who you are it's a super
grounding experience as well
so yes michelle b i say it's a good
thing keep doing it
even if you're in a good place um
miragee how long does it take to
discover
our why can we do it by ourselves or do
we need someone's help
so the exact amount of time it's like
how long does it take to ride a bicycle
you know there is a process and if you
follow the process 100 of people
can learn to write a bicycle it's the
same with the y some people have a
slightly easier time it'd go a little
quicker some people uh it takes a little
longer there's no right or wrong or good
or bad it's just what it is
um some people choose to do it slower
they want to
take their time to do it and and do it
over the course of uh a few weeks we've
even heard people doing it over the
course of
a few months they want to revisit it
some people want to sit down and do it
in a weekend
so it's really up to you how long it
takes um and the question is can we do
it by ourselves or do we need someone's
help
so technically you could do it by
yourself
in my experience it's way more difficult
for the simple reason is it's very hard
to have objectivity
about ourselves we can't see ourselves
the same way other people see us we
don't see how we're being received
and to have someone's help as we're
telling the stories to see the patterns
um is amazing when i do y discoveries
for people they'll tell me a bunch of
stories
and like the the pattern will be so
clear and i'll say to them
do you see the pattern in all the
stories you just told me and they'll
look at me like
no and i'm like you literally use the
same words
in every story and they're like i did
that's my point it's really hard to have
that kind of
objectivity and that kind of perspective
when you do it alone so i strongly
strongly strongly
strongly recommend you do it with
someone
but we usually caution don't do it with
a spouse or a sibling or a parent those
relationships are too close
because they think they know you better
um okay
uh should we take one live from the
instagram
um what else these are all questions
related to
finding our why uh hello brazil
hello kurdistan love that um
we have a good question from kelly c
kelly c go ahead where's she where's she
asking the question from
i lost her okay but kelly c asks what
are you listening for in the stories
people tell when you're helping them
find their why
your podcast guests often recount their
first story is not
the one um so what am i listening for
when people tell me the stories
um uh so
she said in the podcast when and i asked
people to tell me stories
they say it's not the one i think more
so how do you find the right story how
do you know the stories
oh got it god i got it so how do i get
people to tell me the stories okay
so the the the big word for me when we
when i'm helping somebody find their why
is the word specific the word specific i
just did one for a friend a few days ago
and i said you know um you know tell me
something you've done in your career
tell me something specific
you've done in your career that you
loved being a part of
and she she told me oh i loved when i
was working in a doctor's office
and i was like yeah but you've done that
many times tell me one she's like well i
always liked it
those are not helpful um and so the
the where i get sort of a little pushy
is i push people to
and i use i use different techniques to
get them to go specific i say tell me
one specific
example of what you're saying about as
if it were a movie that i can relive
with you tell me one thing that happened
and sometimes they'll start giving me a
generic one um
and i'll always interrupt so you want
specific stories
specific stories are the key because the
more specific they are
they get lost in the story if they're
not specific they try to start
interpreting the stories and start
looking for the patterns
and doing the analysis for me i don't
need their help in the analysis i'm
i'm the one doing the active listening i
just want them to get lost and tell the
story
um and so i've even said that to people
please stop doing the analysis for me
please just tell me the story um about
what uh what you experienced
so that's the way you get stories out of
people
and the last story people to get stories
out of us um here's one
from yen l uh sometimes i find myself
losing sight of my why how can we
continually
remind ourselves to live in alignment
with our why
fantastic question super difficult so
there are many things one is
surround yourself with little symbols or
talismans or reminders of your why
i do that um i have lots of little
things over the years that i've
collected that just remind me of my why
they could be a picture on a desktop of
something that reminds you
i often recommend to people to find a
physical object that reminds you of it
and
uh put it by your bed or put it on your
desk for me
if any of you have uh known me for any
time the color orange
has become really important the sorry
those such
chips coming back up um the color orange
has become really important because for
me it's the color of optimism and it
reminds me
that my why is to inspire people to do
the things that inspire them
you know when you see orange staying
standing out in something even the
second hand on my watch
is orange if you go back and watch my
original ted talk you'll see my my watch
was completely orange
orange plays a central theme in my life
why
because it reminds me of why i do what i
do um
also uh having friends who sometimes say
um this is not like you or you seem out
of balance or is everything okay
um but yeah surround yourself with
little reminders um i sometimes for
years i had my why
statement literally written by my
computer it's so internalized now i
don't have it anymore
but for a long time i had it written on
a post-it right on my computer and i
would replace it
every now and then with with just new
handwriting so write it down
put it around you put it by your bed put
it on your desk find
objects um and it keeps you focused
we have a good question from zoe from
canada zoe from canada yes zoe from
canada
asks can your why change over the years
as your business and personal life
change and evolve
ah great zoe asks can your why
change over the years as your business
and personal life
change over the years the simple answer
is no
we only have one why and it is fully
formed by the time
we are probably in our mid to late teens
we are who we
are and the rest of our lives offer us
opportunities
to live in balance with that why or not
the rest of our lives present
myriad choices that we have to make and
the question is will we make a choice
that keeps us aligned with our why or
puts us out of balance from our why
so absolutely i would hope that we're
growing professionally and personally
and what you'll probably find is that
with your wire front and center it's
actually becoming
brighter and brighter meaning you're
making better decisions more decisions
that are keeping you in balance in other
words i hope you're growing and getting
happier and more confident as you get
older not the opposite
your why can help help do that but we
are who we are we are
we are the sum totals of how we were
raised the experiences we had when we
were kids
that made us who we are the only
question is whether we're making
decisions
that that uh amplify the best of who we
are
so yes one y your whole life um
let's see uh i should probably label
which ones i've
crossed them off so i know where i am
okay leslie m
hello leslie uh what might the impact of
people's lives be
if they were taught about knowing their
why at a young age
should it be in the curriculum oh my
goodness i love this well there is an
age that's too young
um the youngest i've done it for was
somebody who was 16
and uh they actually used it to write
their college essay to help them get
into the
the university of their choice um so i
absolutely think
uh i would love to see it in curriculum
can you imagine if we taught all high
school seniors or at least high school
juniors
what their why was how they would choose
a whether they want to go to college or
not and if they do what college they
want to go to
and if they don't what career they want
to follow what their first job will be
can you imagine if when a guidance
counselor sits
down with you sits down with them that
that why is used to help
offer the guidance you know as opposed
to generic guidance counselor advice
or if we get to college um same thing oh
i would love that i know a lot of
companies do that you know a lot of
companies uh
work to help their people find their why
when they're when they join the company
we do that
um because it helps us know who someone
is and helps them know who they are
and it's really powerful um so yeah i'd
love to see it for entry level employees
i'd love to see it in
in universities for sure and i'd love to
see it in high schools
uh for juniors and seniors i think that
would be really amazing so yes
it should be in the curriculum leslie i
completely
agree with you graham do you have
another one for me yes i've got a great
one andreas asks can we define a
business
by the way andreas asks can you define a
business by the y
absolutely a y is ostensibly an
origin story it's where we come from all
businesses have a founding they also
were birthed they come from somewhere so
absolutely
an organization can absolutely have a
why and it's that why
that helps us feel connected to that
organization whether an employee
or as a customer or even as a
shareholder which is we want to
feel connected to that organization to
their purpose to their cause to their
belief
that in some way shape or form that
company is helping
us realize our own purpose cause and
belief
so yes companies do have a why the
problem is most companies either don't
know them
or they don't follow them they became
obsessed with other things
other than advancing a purpose cause or
belief also a why is what establishes
the values of a company
and um and though the products may
change and culture may change and
politics may change and technology may
change
our values should be immutable our
values should be
fixed because that's how people know who
we are it creates expectations
okay uh suzanne asks
uh once our why is determined what are
some
practical ways to utilize it that uh in
building career decisions and life moves
etc
um so uh i we so i wrote
a book called start with why and the
reason i called it start with why is
because learning your why
like college graduation is a
commencement it is the beginning of
something
not the end of something you go through
the process to start something
the opportunity then as suzanne asked as
well how do i use it
well the hard part is you can use it so
many places
knowing your why helps make better
decisions about friends believe it or
not people we date believe it or not
i love learning people's why's because i
can actually
feel if i have a connection to them or
not people who i really get along with
when i learn their why
i immediately know what it is that draws
me to them because the why is the value
they have their wise the value they have
in my and all their friends lives
my why is the value i offer the world
it's the value that uh
uh i feel in my in my friends and
colleagues as well
it is our contribution right um so
um a better way another way to use a y
very practically
um is in writing a resume for example a
lot of people
write uh the first thing on their resume
they write objective
to get a job with a reputable companies
no kidding you're applying for a job
that's the purpose of the resume what i
always recommend is get rid of the
objective statement
and put your y at the top of the
statement but put your y
um front and center at the top of a
resume because then what the resume does
it provides the proof it provides the
context and so if you have good uh
because everybody puts on their resume
you know all their jobs and how
wonderful every job was not true
um but when you put your wire front and
center you can actually have a much more
honest conversation about
ah this job was amazing my why was able
to come to life and look at all the
successes i had and the joy i had
this one was more of a struggle and i
realized i took the job for the wrong
reasons i took it
because it offered me more money than an
alternative and boy did i make a mistake
the point is it's an honest conversation
but that would be a weird conversation
to have without context
so i'm a great believer in putting the
why front and center i think we still
have it online
we used to offer or teach a class like i
remember on how to write a resume on how
to
i think we still have it find a job you
love oh yeah we still have that i think
so on
on our on our website uh we have a class
called how to find a job you love
and that very much puts the y front and
center
um from david yes david
my why is still in its early stage it's
just an idea and a rough concept and
it's not fully formed
how can i get it across the finish line
into an actual statement
so david has all the components of his
why but he doesn't have a statement
okay there's two answers to to this
david
sometimes the language that we're
working in fails us
i i work in english and sometimes the
english language
just doesn't have the words that capture
the essence of the why sometimes it's
very clunky it's true
it's just not very pretty um i have uh
one person i helped him do his why
um and it was so sort of
convoluted in how we had to describe it
even though he understood it perfectly
and he's like that's it
that we just said big boat little boat
that's all he said he knows what it
means
but it's a convoluted way for him to say
it about how he
operates between two worlds it's so
sometimes
language just lets us down um but if you
have all the components um
what i would recommend is practice
practice um
you know the other thing you can use is
one of your origin stories one of your
stories from childhood
um when somebody says so what do you do
you know what makes you special makes
you stand out you know
you're at a dinner party and somebody
says so tell me about yourself you can
say well
when i was a kid and you tell this that
story say and basically i've been doing
that the rest of my life
you're telling them you're why you just
don't have the why statement
i'm a great believer in dinner parties
and sitting next to people on planes
you know whenever we're allowed to go
back to different parties again i think
it's getting closer
um uh uh um
uh but when you're in a in a space
that's not professional
to practice using your why and see what
lands when i learned my why
i promise you it took me about a hundred
attempts or more
when i would say my why statement and
people look me like i had
three heads um so practice david
practice but also tell those origin
stories and you'll find that you might
find language in there as well
on that note j deep asked what is your
own why assignment
my why jd is to inspire people to do the
things that inspire them
so together each of us can change our
world for the better
that is why i get out of bed every
morning and it is it is the greatest
compliment someone can ever pay me
when i when somebody reads my book or
sees a talk or something that i've done
and somebody says you were so inspiring
or that inspired me
or you're working that's like the
greatest compliment you can give me
because that is my purpose and that word
that word fuels me
you'll notice the word inspire comes up
a lot i made t-shirts that have the word
inspire
in on them why because i wanted to wear
one you'll see the word inspire used in
all of our products in a lot of places
um that's because that's the
contribution we're attempting to make in
the world so that's my why
um i have one here from kashif kashif
asks
is knowing our why limited to running a
business only uh absolutely not as we've
discussed
already you can uh apply it wherever
um a y is a description of who you are
if you're doing a personal why versus a
company's why but if you're doing your
personal why
it captures it captures what inspires
you it captures what
would it the flame that burns inside you
um it captures your value to the world
um so
every single human being has a god-given
right to uh they have they have their
own why
our eyes are unique to us um
and uh and uh yeah it's what makes us
special and stand out
um and it's why we and one of the fun
things is
like we meet lots of people but we're
not friends with everyone how come
we're friends with people who we see the
world the same way or we share their
values or we get along with them
and the funny thing is in when you hear
the why of all your friends you like oh
yeah that's why we're friends
because it all sort of comes together
and your why's go nicely together
laura b and kurt g
ask why is it so difficult for
organizations
and traditional command and control
leaders to move from what
we what we do to why we do it how do we
help shift
that in our organizations great question
the reason is
super super simple what is tangible and
easy to count
and easy to measure why is intangible
it's ethereal it's hard to grasp
which is why i believe in specific
stories and telling specific stories
because it helps make
tangible that which is intangible um
and and leaders who are incentivized or
driven uh
by uh by results alone
where all of their incentive structures
are forcing them to only look
at that which is tangible and that which
is measurable but we know what happens
when you do that
it comes everything comes at a cost so
for example
an organization needs to save money or
boost profitability
well i can look at laying off 10 of my
workforce
and i can look at the numbers and count
the numbers i can see how it's going to
increase my profitability and how it's
going to
boost my uh reduce my expenses it's
right here it's black and white super
simple
i mean it seems like the smartest
decision in the world to make great
layoff 10 of my company destroys the
culture destroys trust with management
destroys trust with human resources
creates tension amongst employees you
have those who didn't get laid off have
survivors guilt because their friends
got laid off
and you're literally creating years of
new problems
um makes it harder to hire makes it
harder to keep the best people
literally from this one choice because
someone
was excessively focused on the tangible
over the
intangible excessively focused on the
what versus the why you ask how do we
shift our organizations
keep talking about the why keep leading
with the why you keep doing it yourself
you cannot change the way another leader
leads you can only take responsibility
for the way
you lead be the leader you wish you had
do that
and things start to spread
we've got a great one from basilis from
earlier
everyone has a very specific why but are
how's
also specific or are they more dynamic
and evolving
everybody has a specific why but are
how's uh dynamic and evolving
um so think of a wine house kind of like
the components of a fingerprint
um so you are who you are um so your why
is the is the is the flame inside you
it's what inspires you
it's sort of the thing that just really
captures
the essence of who you are and the value
you provide to the world your values are
how you go about delivering on that
in other words they're your your unique
selling propositions they're your
strengths
um and those should also remain pretty
immutable so for me one of
one of my values is keep it simple well
you'll see it in my work
i might work very hard to take sometimes
complex things and make them easy to
understand
i've been doing it my whole life i had
to it was a you know goes back to my
childhood as a survival mechanism as a
kid with adhd
who still had to get through school so i
had to i had to learn to understand and
ask questions and simplify
um another one of my values a silver
line it which means find the silver
lining
in every cloud i've been doing that when
i'm at my natural best
i'm doing that so again what you'll find
in how you do things is when you're
operating
in flow when you're operating at your
natural best then yes
uh all of those values are there and
they they pretty much don't
change your whole life it's again it's
about opportunity to bring them to bear
it's
it's how you operate at your natural
best um
so yeah you might find nuance as you get
older but the odds are very high they're
going to remain
the same uh jerry s how did the pi
not jerry seinfeld uh jerry seinfeld
asks no i'm just kidding although it
could be i don't know i don't know who
jerry s
is how did the pandemic change the way
you think about defining and
communicating
the why it didn't change anything
what it made me do what it did for me is
it
reinforced the importance of knowing
your why and talking about it
the why during the pandemic especially
when it first started and there was
so much confusion we didn't know how to
get it we didn't know what was safe we
didn't know who was safe it was such
chaos um having the y was something very
grounding
and we as an organization and me as an
individual i re we referred back to our
why constantly
because it gave us a sense of stability
that with the world moving and chaotic
around us
something something remained fixed
you'll have a very similar experience if
you have a close loving relationship
that when there's chaos there's
stability in the relationship that
actually helps you manage the chaos
so if anything the pandemic reinforced
the importance of value
of knowing my why knowing one's why
this is great graham what else do we
have yeah we have
a good one here um
i'm looking i'm looking on instagram as
well what do you have here jennifer asks
how would one was raised in a
dysfunctional family know that their why
is
genuine and authentic as opposed from a
false belief system
and unhealthy coping mechanisms
okay that okay let's let's
come closer sir because i don't think i
can resp i can get
just say it just say it out loud so that
nice people can hear what you said
how would one who was raised in a
dysfunctional family
know that their why is genuine and
authentic as opposed
from false belief systems and unhealthy
coping mechanisms
which serve their purpose in childhood
yet do not as an adult
wow okay okay thank you for that
question
jennifer jennifer what a vulnerable
question i love that okay
let's unpack that so uh we are the sum
total of how we were raised and the
experiences we had we when we were kids
good or bad
and what i find remarkable when i've
done these and i've asked people tell me
a specific
early happy childhood memory and
sometimes
somebody will stare at me and very
uncomfortably say i did not have a happy
childhood
i don't have any happy memories and i'll
say well tell me
a sad one then and i'll and so here's
one of the actual things that somebody
told me
um they had a very a very abusive father
and one of the things they remember is
uh
her and her brother her baby brother
hiding from their father when he went on
a
on a rampage and she remembers holding
her brother and covering him up while
they hid in the closet
and she tells this traumatic difficult
sad story and it occurred to me while i
was listening to the story i said
you told me about how you made specific
attempt to cover your brother to protect
your brother
that's positive in other words what
you'll find is even in difficulty
you will find these these these
strengths
that come out and that's who this person
was this person at her core
was a protector that she would stand in
the way of those
who who might be harmed in other words
it was very very positive
i'm a great believer in the world of
balance that
there's a cost for everything that is
good that happens to us where everything
we gain
comes at a cost but everything bad um
also offers
some silver lining there's always a
positive in something bad that happens
as well
so the the the one of the dirty secrets
about finding your why is you actually
don't have to have happy childhood
memories you just have to have childhood
memories
and there are still patterns in there
that reveal who you actually are
and so some of those coping mechanisms
though in their specific form
jennifer they may not be applicable as
an adult i would venture to say that
there's still some things that came out
of that that help
make you who you are that offer you
great value i've talked about it before
i was a kid with adhd
back then it wasn't diagnosable i was
just hyperactive and didn't focus and
got in trouble a lot for not doing my
homework
and um and so i still had to get through
school
and so i learned to ask questions and
listen intently
because that's the only way i could
learn because i couldn't read the
textbook
i would go after class and talk to
teachers it was all survival mechanism
but it's those coping mechanisms as a
kid
have translated into becoming strengths
as an adult and i i'm a great believer
that the solutions we find to our
struggles as children
very often become our strengths as
adults so
that's an intense question um but i i
promise you
that if you can tell those specific
stories you will find a wealth
of wonderful positive stories that make
you who you are today and make you
remarkable
and that's the same for all of us yeah
great stuff this is great how do we
apply well hold on one second let me do
one from instagram
uh um uh here we go
we kind of answered this one before but
it's the one in front of me how do you
find
your this is from ex detects uh
how do you find your whys in life how
can
can you have multiple wise at certain
stages of your life no you only have one
why
um and i love it when people say well my
professional y and my personal y's like
you only have one y
you know why because it's you because
it's you um
and you are still you um though you may
grow and change and
other things about you and you hopefully
become more grounded in your why
um you do not have multiple wise if you
do think you have multiple y's
then how can they all be accurate how
can they all be true
the reality is is you're either
splitting it apart so it might actually
be a description of hows
or one of them isn't true if you're
different at home than you are at work
in one of those two places you're lying
uh lee uh oh there's another one from
instagram
um we how do you make it just stop
scrolling i just have to hold it right
uh how do you uh we think about why but
we also need to explain how
yes we do uh in what ways can we make
this connection
how to find our why and explain our
house when we practice it
it's one of the things that's actually
in the y discovery course we do both
we help people understand their why and
it's also
whenever i try and help people find
these things it's the whole process
um and when you go through the process
you're gonna have all these stories and
all of these things that you do
and what you'll find is like a lot of
them are actions house or actions things
you do
the way you see the world things like
that but one of them
usually feels bigger that it bubbles up
one of them is more emotional than the
others the other sort of things you do
but
and that's usually the why so the
process believe it or not reveals all of
them at the same time
it's the question one of the challenges
is picking out the one that's actually
the why one of the one that one of the
why
one of the things that's actually bigger
than the other so the process
uh considers all of that um
here's one from lee c um
is this whole why thing really
applicable to ordinary people
or is it just something uh for gravy
trained management consultants i love
this
for instance uh does a tesco shell
stacker really need oi
or can they uh just be doing their job
to pay the bills okay
knowing your why and the reason why you
take your work are entirely different
things
an organization that wants to offer
their people a sense of belonging
cares about their why an organization
that wants to
define value based on their contribution
to the world or to people
and not just in uh in financial terms
cares about their why
and anybody who it's you know
when you say when you say does a tesco
shelf stacker really need a why why not
they're a human being are they not
entitled to happiness and confidence and
and purpose and belonging are they not
entitled to manage their life in a way
that brings them joy and inspiration
everyone is entitled to that
i i think we have to be careful careful
about
um about viewing someone's job
and saying how can they be happy i know
some people who do what
what uh lee may consider menial labor
who are incredibly happy and fulfilled
and they love the people they work for
and they see their job as contributing
um uh to the lives of other people
and i know some people in big fancy jobs
and make lots of money and
you know have fame who are unhappy
because it's it's all about the stuff
so so absolutely absolutely
um absolutely a shelf stacker at tesco's
um uh is entitled to know their way not
at sainsbury's they're not entitled to
no just just test goes
um but yeah no i i uh uh
every human being is entitled has a why
is entitled to know it right
that's that's part of the why i do what
i do which is i said a long time ago i
want a golden circle on every desk
you when you hear my vision i imagine a
world in which the vast majority of
people
wake up every single morning inspired
feel safe wherever they are and end the
day
fulfilled by the work that they do i
literally mean anyone and everyone who
wants that
um regardless of where they are or their
lot in life
that is the contribution that we are
making this is what this movement is
we're all a part of it
that's why we're here okay
yeah we've got how do we apply the y to
finding dates
partners marriage and relationships as a
whole how do we find our why to find
dates
partners and relationships as a whole so
um
what i think is really interesting is
think of a date like uh
like a job interview right um and think
of a job interview like a date
right so um if you went on a on a first
date with someone
and they sat down they said you know
[Music]
i'm extremely rich i've made lots of
money
i do lots of cool things i met a lot of
famous people um
i go on tv all the time which is good
because i'm really good looking uh
yeah yeah would you want to go on a
second date with them right
not very appealing it's also not very
appealing when we sit down for a job
interview and just tell people how great
we are and all the things that we've
done
it's the same kind of thing now imagine
if you knew your why
and you're making conversation with
someone
and they say so you know where you from
would you know tell me a little bit
about you
and you say you know i
love what i do i love my life i love my
job
you can say i i i wake up every day to
inspire people to do the things that
inspire them
and for me the challenge is finding all
the different ways
that i could do it and i've been really
really
grateful for the path that it's taken me
and i've i've made some money and i've
get to
go on tv which is fun because i'm really
good looking and you can see how all the
same jokes and all the same things
now have a context and that's what y
does it provides context
it also helps you connect with somebody
that when somebody's telling you about
themselves and you ask some
questions and you get to know them a
little bit you realize that maybe their
values are completely different than
yours
so why gives you clarity and confidence
in who you are and what you need around
you um but it also helps you present
yourself in a way that's way more
authentic
now there's a there's a there's a rub to
the why that i don't talk about that
often
um uh because you really have to get
good at uh giving your why
before you can deal with this but the
the difficult part about knowing your
why is the thing that you give to the
world the value you give
and offer to other people is also the
thing you need
the most so it's one so one of the ways
to
to to understand the people in our lives
partners and mates is can they actually
give us the thing
that we give to other people can they
refuel our why
as we as we spend it to give it to other
people so that's that's a big part of it
as well
so for me the hardest part for me is i
need people to inspire me to do what is
uh to do what i love also um so
yeah this is why i'm friends with folk
this is why i'm drawn to people
who live lives of service because it
inspires me
so much um good question um
i had one in here that i liked i lost
the question but i remember what it was
it was something to the effect of
um how do we live our why and how do we
inspire people around us we're the
low person on the totem pole um
um um well you cannot change
uh the way our we can't change the way
our leaders lead like i wish we could
you know no number of anonymously sent
books will suddenly change the way that
they lead
um uh if we can keep trying but it won't
work um
we have to be the leaders we wish we had
and so we can't change the way somebody
three four five levels above us is
leading the company
but we can take responsibility for how
the people to the left of us and how the
people to the right of us
feel when they come to work and by the
way the person who we work for
our boss they're a human being too and
though they may be difficult or
sometimes maybe they're an [ __ ]
do we really know why are they just a
genetic [ __ ]
they may be it absolutely is a
possibility
or maybe they're under extreme stress
that we don't know about
or maybe their bus is an extreme [ __ ]
it just filters down
or maybe they were never taught how to
lead and they're just trying to make the
best of it and they're lying hiding and
faking every day
but there's so many reasons and so
sometimes going into our boss's office
and saying hey you were really you're
really tough of a tough on us
in the meeting today i just wanna make
sure you're okay are you okay
i'm worried about you like we've all
been going through a lot during this
coveted time for example
and so have you um so
being a leader doesn't just mean being a
leader to the people on our level it
means being a leader to the people
around us
and so the way we lead from the bottom
of the totem pole is the exact same
way we lead from every level of the
totem pole which is
uh we take care of those around us um
and we'd be the leaders we wish we had
that is
leadership has nothing to do with rank
it has nothing to do with where we sit
on the totem pole
it's how we take care of those around us
remember leadership is the awesome
responsibility
to see those around us rise okay let's
take some more
andrea asks what if our why scares us
and we feel like no one really sees it
in us could it be that we have the wrong
why oh we still go for it i love that
that's such a
that's such a complicated thought she
says what if our andreas what if our y
scares us um and and we fear that people
won't see
it do we abandon it or do we just go for
it okay so there's two thoughts there
that are worth unpacking okay if other
people don't see it
okay that's let's let's deal with that
first because i think that's a little
that's a little simpler
um if other people don't see it then the
question is are we showing it
right and so many of us all of us
especially at various times
we're all lying hiding and faking at
various points right
somebody asks a question you know that
makes us uncomfortable in a public forum
sometimes we agree to something we say
yes even though it's not true
because we just don't embarrass
ourselves we're very often inauthentic
plus we live in an instagram facebook
tech talkable world
we're all presenting ourselves and
curating ourselves as how we want to be
so we're really good at showing people
the kind of person we want to be
it's kind of ironic as well if you think
about relationships
um you know we present ourselves as the
as our best selves
but it's only really when our
vulnerabilities and insecurities are
revealed
can love exist um that's that magical
authenticity so i would argue that if
if the world doesn't see who you are you
know are there ways that you can share
it with the world
in a way that is inspiring um to them
and
and authentic to you um uh how you show
up
you know uh sometimes the clothes you
wear sometimes it's it's silly stuff
um you know i i always i would often
wear
bright brightly colored ties in college
i know a little nerdy
but um one because it sort of was a
reflection of my independence i didn't
dress like everyone else
but i it also made people smile i would
catch them seeing my
my time it would make them smile and and
i liked that um
and so there are lots of little things
we can do personally
to bring our why to life now what i'm
really interested in is what you said
andrea
when you said what if our why scares us
now if it's actually scary because it's
dangerous or difficult then maybe it's
not fully our why
if it scares us but because we are
afraid that others will judge us for
what it is
like this is truly who i am this is why
i wake up out of bed every morning
you know then then i think you have to
go for it now the question is do you
have to jump in the deep end
i think that's a question of your own
risk tolerance i think there's nothing
wrong with wading into the water
starting in the shallow end i mean think
about it look what i do for a living
inspire people that do the things that
inspire them like how corny and cheesy
is that
right like i'm fully aware of that when
i first started talking about it people
were like
well that's cheesy i'm like i know i
know and so
i i but i still would do it and was it a
jumping in the deep end
no i would dip my toe and i would test
things out you know
and i would try things out not see how
it was received and sometimes it went
well and sometimes it didn't go well
i was learning to swim with my why is
basically was my why
floaties i was wearing why floaties
that's what i was doing um
so yeah i think if it's if you if it
feels right because that's the test of a
why
you know does it feel right does it feel
like who i am does it give you chills or
goosebumps or does it make you well up
when you think about it does it excite
you
uh then it's probably accurate and yeah
then you're gonna have to
at least get in the shallow end you dip
your foot in and try try using it at
certain places
and as you get more comfortable you'll
learn to swim uh graham
i'm out of questions over here so we can
let me see if i got any over here from
from the gram um uh thanks everyone for
sticking around by the way
we've been going for over 40 minutes and
and look how many people are still here
joining me
i love it i'm gonna have a little drink
because my voice is getting a little
hoarse we've got one from
uh linda linda asks we have a few
questions that concern
uh age and the why okay lots of
questions about age and the why let's
hear linda's question linda says
at 62 is my why a look back
or a look forward so linda asks at 62 is
my why i look back or i look forward
the good news is linda a why is always
looking back
it is an origin story it's where we come
from
um and so um one of the things that i've
always actually wanted to do
i've always wanted to start a project
where i can help people who are
terminally ill
learn their why so they can look back at
their lives
and and see um see the value that
they've
that they've offered and and can pass on
um with peace and confidence um and so
the age that we find roi is completely
irrelevant it's a
as i said it's a it's when when somebody
truly learns their why
there's an excitement that comes over
them there's a calm
and con confidence that comes over them
and there's a clarity that they gain
and looking back and understanding and
seeing the patterns when things worked
and didn't work
is actually very calming and confident
um so at 62 years old
looking back um one of the advantages
you have at 62
that somebody who's 16 or 19 or 20
doesn't have
is you have way more life experience and
so you have way more stories to call
upon
and way more pattern way more places to
find the patterns so it's actually a
little easier
believe it or not because you just have
more more data
so it's 62 it's uh you have lots and
lots of data to to color
call through to uh to get your why so
yeah yeah please do it somebody said why
floaties yes we should produce white
floaties
merch merch floaties with why why am i
swimming
yeah when i was a little kid little
aside just occurred to me talking about
confidence
so i was learning to swim and like so
many little kids
i had floaties i i grew up not in
america so we called them armbands
right so i wore armbands uh and uh
and my mother as i was learning swim
would let out
the air you know slowly so you know if i
went from really full to slowly letting
out the air
and at one point they had no air in them
zero and i would put them on and jump on
the pool and my mother said you you know
you can swim like you don't need
your armbands and i refuse to take them
off because i couldn't swim without them
even though they had no air in them i
didn't understand physics at the age
uh but uh yeah and they were just kept
falling off and i just keep pulling them
back on
while i was in the water um you know so
uh
that's my little unrelated floaty story
my little armband story
i think let's take two more questions
we've got um
one that's very interesting and one
that's a little tougher which one you
want uh
let's do the tough question first okay
we gotta talk
it's tough okay for talking with family
that is anxious you won't be financially
stable in pursuing your why
okay okay the question was
any advice about how to talk to family
uh because of the their fear
that if you pursue your why you will not
be financially stable
okay yes that is a misunderstanding
of the why right you're probably talking
about
what you want to do that is maybe not
financially viable to your family
but it hasn't it is not about why you're
doing it right
so for example you can say my why is to
be an actor and your family's like
really please don't you know um
be an accountant you know families are
really practical um
uh being an actor is not your why being
a painter is not your why
um they are they are ways in which you
found to bring your why to life
and so we have a few actors and a few
performers on our team
and uh and they have said to us
that they have found similar kinds of
fulfillment
in the work they do with us than they
did on the stage because it was not
about the performance performance just
one way in which they could
bring their why to life um it's
it might be about uh sharing stories or
or giving of self or creating emotional
uh creating a a safe emotional space for
people
um and there are many many many ways you
can do that some are profitable and some
are not profitable
i think a healthy life is a little bit
like a healthy art collection
a healthy art collection has a range of
emotions and i think a healthy life
is finding multiple ways to bring your
why to life
it's your why should come to life as a
friend it can come as your hobbies
professionally again um and you may
still choose
to pursue a career um that your family
disapproves of
um but i think when the question your
question was how do i
uh have the conversation with my family
to truly talk about your why and help
them understand who you are
and then you say so let's just use mine
as an example i want to inspire people
to do
the things that inspire them and there
are many ways i can do it as you know
um however the one that brings me the
most joy the ones that i've found that i
can connect
most easily with is when i paint or when
i act whatever it is
and i can look in the audience and i can
see the impact that i'm having
and i really want to pursue that for a
while because i feel that it gives me
it brings my why to life but i can
promise you that there are other ways
and i'll explore those also
so it does help with the conversation
because a y provides
context for the choices you make and so
give your family context
don't just say but it's my passion right
they won't understand that
uh we have a fun one can a country have
a why
i love that can a country have a why yes
yes because a country is an organization
of people with values
um uh and not only does a country have a
why a country has
has values and and and just like people
or jobs
sometimes we feel like we belong there
and sometimes we don't
sometimes we have weird loyalty to a
country even though the conditions may
be more difficult
than if we moved because we love our
countries we love our friends we
love our jobs even though i could get
paid more somewhere else
i love it working here so absolutely
people emigrate
you know they go to a new country
because they say i didn't quite
fit in where i come from so i moved
states can have wise
cities can have wise and what's really
funny is just like people and just like
companies
you can see how their why shows up in
their economies
or in their personalities so for example
the germans or the swiss like really
into super super super super high
quality
detail things like that right and then
you look at the people who are making
all those high quality products
you know we make fun of the germans
because they don't have a sense of humor
well that's because they don't have a
sense of humor
um uh and they don't even know that i'm
joking
because they didn't have a sense of
humor and didn't know that that was a
joke
um my point is is i i kid uh
uh um we all know the germans have a
sense of humor
um uh my point is is you can start to
see in what in the products that that
that um that economies produce you can
get a sense of their of their
personalities
so you take a look at america lots of
innovation that comes out of america but
we're also like always on to the next
always on to the next
uh we're constantly redoing things
redoing things not a lot of patience
uh here because it's so entrepreneurial
um so yeah it's it's really funny when
you look at um you know
uh uh when you look at um uh
the personality of of a country
absolutely think of them as a person
and it all makes perfect sense um okay
if you could
drop your why if you think you know your
why drop it in the chat let other people
see
i love reading them myself um uh
and and then i think we're gonna wrap up
um
thank you everyone for joining what do i
have to do oh sorry i have a closing
here
uh thanks so much for joining us and
continuing to spread the wine message
i have to say that sorry thank you so
much for joining us and helping us
continue to spread the message of why
lord knows i can't do it alone and i
need all the help i can get because
remember what we said before we want to
get a y uh we want everyone to find
their where i want to get a golden
circle in every desk
and this is a movement and it's about
helping it's a
it's more it's it's bigger than just us
finding our why
it's how can we help our friends and our
colleagues find their why that's what i
want us to commit to
which is helping other people find their
why and learning yours is just one of
the tools to help other people find
theirs
if you want to find your why or refresh
your why
be sure to check the new find your why
course the new find your way on demand
course on simonsenic.com
i recorded it myself it was so much fun
i got jake over here who's helping me
out today
who helped me record it and we had a
blast making it and uh we had a lot of
fun
um and so if you're looking for uh to go
through
an on-demand course to find your why do
check out
find your why and uh for the next 24
hours
um if you use the code y time
w-h-y-t-i-m-e in other words
it's y time uh uh you'll get 20
off that on-demand course just for
people who are tuning in today because
i'm so grateful that you're here that
you're part of the movement
it's um our way of of saying thank you
and giving a little back
and if you've already found your why uh
then give that code
to someone who's looking for it um i
think that's all we got
uh for those of you who are in the
united states have a happy
memorial day and a nice long weekend for
those of you in other places
um uh i know that we're all in different
stages of the pandemic
um i wish you uh good luck good fortune
godspeed and
take care of each other as best you can
and on that thank you for joining
it's really fun to do these take care of
yourself take care of each other